from 11 and 5 and 2017 to 5 and 11 and
2018 one of the biggest disappointments
last year and I think it all flows from
sorry Blake bad quarterback play yeah
the perception that there was a double
standard that they were protecting Blake
bortles right making excuses for Blake
bortles yeah and I think that wears down
a team and I just think that they they
thought they were good enough to
essentially fast forward to the playoffs
once they beat the Patriots in week two
they thought just take us to January
we're ready to go and they lost sight of
what it takes to win week after week and
not having that quarterback play yeah
not having that kind of leadership that
you need not having the respect for the
quarterback this year they've got it
with Nick Foles I think this year's
gonna be dramatically different all
because of the presence of Nick Foles
yeah I agreed I look at Jacksonville I
think the first thing I think of is go I
go watch out I mean again I think this
is an extremely talented football team
that guess if I had a you know mark two
or three teams in football that I'd say
dramatic changes dramatic difference as
far as win-loss total and a team that I
think is dangerous in the AFC it would
start with the Jacksonville Jaguars
there's not very many weaknesses on the
roster you talked about it yeah last
year of course the quarterback play has
kind of been a struggle there in
Jacksonville it won't be anymore
last year injuries did hurt them so I'll
say that much as well and that didn't
help Blake bortles chances as far as
executing a good offense and all that -
offensive line issues Leonard fournette
got hurt all of those things kind of
snowball their emotions their immaturity
I think got all the best of them but man
Mike I mean you know I know you hear me
talk about I got a man crushing their
defense I still look at the defensive
line and go oh my gosh it's one of the
best in football you know you look at
linebacker
yeah there's no tellin Smith but they
got a guy like Josh Allen who a lot of
people compared to Anthony Barr coming
out so he might be able to fill that
role and play the stand up linebacker
position even if telemon smith is
doesn't play and doesn't we never see
him again
they still got other players that I
think are good in that position
secondary we know it's phenomenal I mean
you go through it you know the only
position on the team all offensive line
I like Leonard fournette I know we both
like Nick Foles only position on the
team that's maybe a little unproven is
the wide receiver position and I love
Dede Westbrook yes that's why they have
a lot of
guys that have big-time potential and
you know again Doug morones and
offensive line coach so I always trust
their offensive line evaluations Tom
Coughlin xanex wide receiver coach he's
got an eye for wide receivers why do you
think the Giants have had wide receivers
for like 15 years straight over there
because Tom knows where to find them
finds guys like Victor Cruz whatever it
may be but yeah Dede Westbrook you know
Mark Easley still on the roster Kealing
Cole DJ shark who they drafted in the
second round last year so they've got
some guys at that position that are
talented that just need to kind of rise
to the occasion but I I mean if you had
a pick right now would you go
Jacksonville playoffs if you had if you
had to put put a hundred yes guy offs
yes I would division win I don't know I
think vision vision yeah but I think
Jaguars yes playoffs right yes and then
I mean John Dee Filippo is the new OC
you know will he stay patient I think
this is a great spot for him because he
got Doug Marrone who's an XO line coach
who I think would stay on this what
about learned last year I would hope the
hard way right and now now look in
Minnesota everything got turned upside
down when offensive line coach Tony
Sparano passed a week or so before the
start of training camp they got away
from the run they threw too much there
was a sense D Philip Bo was trying to
audition for his head coach Bobby o line
wasn't good yeah and look at the draft
Josh Allen falls to them at seven right
and they were thrilled by that
development and then go on to I know I
know that's just like the rich got
richer for Jacksonville I mean this is
like they weren't 5 and 11 I know they
were 5 and 11
honey I ran into Sean cone and I think I
mentioned this reason I said hey
congratulations he's out on five 11 I
said no I'm getting Nick falls yeah
obviously they're you know they're
shell-shocked after after the
expectations being so high in 2018 to
fail so badly yeah well in 2017 you know
hey there's they're the ultimate
physicality team I mean if you asked me
about who would be the team's to win in
a bar fight in the NFL if he took the
53-man roster I'd go Jacksonville is
gonna be in the final two or three they
just got so many beasts across the the
whole roster but this year they have an
offense that can help them out you know
I think they wanted to last year thing
and they were gonna replicate 2017 we'll
run the ball and our defense will make a
few plays to hard to win that way you
got to have the offense to be competent
in because
and at times to help that great defense
you